[Music]
and it's interesting here it says the
first blue law although not called that
at the time was enacted in colonial
Virginia in 1610 and it mandated
mandated Church attendance at both
morning and afternoon services on
Sundays a a first time offender lost his
provision and allowance for a whole week
wow thises make me think of buying and
selling you cannot buy or sell because
we're going to apparently they had a
system where there was an allowance
given and if you didn't you weren't seen
at church on Sunday morning and evening
you had your allowance cut off for a
whole week the second offense in
addition to losing his allowance would
be whipped what and a third violation
was supposedly punished by death though
there's debate over whether accounts of
early blue laws were in some cases
exaggerated or not so you think about
this prophetically you're enforcing
worship like Revelation says with the
penalty of losing your allowance or
ability to buy and sell and persecution
and death exactly what Revelation talks
about welcome back everyone to LED live
today we are discussing politics now
don't click away yet this is going to
actually be exciting we are discussing
project
2025 which is kind of like this massive
document
that uh a republican Think Tank has come
up with and we are going to show you how
this actually is uh found in biblical
prophecy so quick quick disclaimer we
are not discussing our own political
views we're not endorsing one party or
the other or putting any party down we
are just discussing the facts so with us
we have James he has a YouTube channel
called biblical hope and you are the
religious liberty leader at your church
so you've brought this presentation uh
for us today awesome well thank you so
much for having me uh it's pleasure to
be here today so uh project 2025 is not
exactly something new the Heritage
foundation's been doing this for a
little while so uh going back to the
1980s back during the Reagan Era you had
their first mandate for leadership which
was presented to Ronald Reagan and
around 60% of the Mandate for
leadership's 2000 plus proposals were
implemented at the end of Reagan's first
year in office and following that time
period there's actually been several
mandates that have uh been presented by
the Heritage Foundation since trying to
establish conservative policies in
United States uh culture yes so that's
kind of what project 2025 is right it's
like this big
document that there's this push for if
Donald Trump specifically mostly of all
the Republican yeah but I think they
mostly want Donald Trump right if if he
gets into power they kind of want to
Lobby to get these policies into place
yeah so this is mandate number nine and
it's a 900 page comprehensive guide with
over 70 plus conservative organizations
that are supporting so if you think
about um you know State Street or if you
think about um Young Americans for
Liberty there's there's a lot of
conservative think tankes they're behind
this not just the Heritage Foundation
and one of the things it does is it
licenses a swift takeover of the
executive branch under a maximalist
version of the unitary executive Theory
now what does that mean um if you think
about it today one of the things we're
seeing more common in politics is the
idea that the president can write an
executive order and make a change in the
executive branch very freely but if we
start abolishing things like
um the independence of the Department of
Justice or the Federal Trade Commission
or the Communications Commission it
allows the United States president to
exert more power and become a dictator
exactly yeah so um they're even taking
it so far as Washington Post noted that
they're planning possibly to invoke the
Insurrection Act of 1807 to deploy the
military for domestic law enforcement
which you know if you think about it
what a power grab that is
I mean it's definitely uh something
significant that they're planning on
doing so this last Point uh Insurrection
Act of 1807 to is that basically saying
that they can enforce martial law or
what is that yeah it's it's taking it to
the point where you know if there's any
dissent if there's any you know violence
or if there's any um opposition to this
kind of uh takeover and power play that
they have the legal authority to go in
and intervene uh as far as that goes
that's scary so yeah there's there's a
lot of people that are kind of afraid
for this that uh something bad could be
happening and you know how fast are they
going to do this well they're taking a
plan here that in the first 180 days of
office they want to implement this plan
so this is something that's going to be
very rapid yeah so um and there's four
pillars that will collectively pave the
way for an effective conservative
Administration it's not just this 900
page document but there's actually a
presidential Administration Academy
there's a Personnel database that
they're looking to establish as well as
an idea that um whatever the President
says in God we trust that that can be
moved forward and so part of their
fourth pillar is actually to implement a
sort of religious element to this that
whatever the the President says in God
we trust or or um you know reference to
Divine Authority there that they can go
ahead and try and implement
um as part of one of the pillars of this
project W what do you guys think about
that is that something that like is that
something we want to go as a direction
in the United States H I don't know I
mean we're considered a Christian Nation
and things like that but the only thing
I know is if the government makes any
kind of rules or laws that contradict or
contrary to the biblical standards or
God's Commandments that we we shouldn't
obey those
laws uh if you have somebody in there
that's saying I'm implementing these
laws because the Bible says
so I don't know what do you guys think
there there is a thing in this country
called separation of church and state
and we can see in history where the
church and state were together right
where for of years the Roman Catholic
Church in the Vatican were basically
ruling in the countries the Nations and
you see how much damage that caed right
millions of Christian lives lost um
millions of people who truly wanted to
genuinely follow the scriptures and they
were killed for it and that's why the US
was founded as separation of church and
state and this is really bringing that
back absolutely I'm glad you brought out
that point because you know one of the
things that we find when we go back to
the history of the Heritage found
which has again touts themselves as
America's Premier conservative think
tank it was actually founded in 1973 by
Paul raych Edwin fuler and Joseph KS but
who are these guys um you know Paul
raych was a Catholic his religious
beliefs significantly influenced his
political activism uh you guys might
have heard of like the Moral Majority
back in the day so it was an idea of of
advancing Conservative Christian values
where Edwin fuler uh he was educated in
Jesuit schooling also a devout Roman
Catholic and then of course we have an
Evangelical on board as well so there's
this idea of Protestants Reaching Across
what was historically a big Gulf and
joining hands with the Roman hierarchy
and the problem that uh every American
ought to have with that is that if you
go back to the encyclicals uh like Quant
Kura in 1864 there was this idea that
religious liberty or Liberty of
conscience and worship is each man's
personal right that's Insanity W they
think that your right to worship God
free from coercion in a constituted
Society is
insanity man that doesn't make any sense
and and we were talking about this
before we start filming this that that
means that anybody who wants to have a
different religion should have the same
right and we as Christians should grant
them that same right if you want to be a
Muslim you should have that right
because God allows for free will now at
the end of course there will be a
judgment Etc but God allows for free
will and that should be upheld you know
I love the idea that true love uh true
worship can only come from the heart you
know the idea of the New Covenant is all
about worshiping God and having having
his law written on our heart and so
where where I see a problem with this is
chapter 16 under the Department of Labor
there's this idea and I'm I'm reading
here from the Mandate that God ordained
the Sabbath as a day of rest and until
very recently the judeo-christian
tradition sought to honor that mandate
by moral and legal regulation of work on
that day however a shared day off makes
it possible for families and communities
to enjoy time off together rather than
atomized
individuals they say that the communal
day of rest has eroded under the
pressures of consumerism and secularism
especially for low-income workers so
here's where the proposal comes in the
idea that the fair labor standards act
federal law should be modified so that
workers be paid time and a half off for
hours worked on the Sabbath so we have
this Union of church and state here and
the day would default to Sunday
why well that was the big argument back
in the uh for years back during like the
Protestant Reformation and uh you know
going back in history um you're looking
at something that some people State
there is over a thousand years of
tradition but there are some others who
disagree with that and point that the
biblical mandate is from Friday Sunset
to Saturday Sunset so there's some
disagreement here and there's an
exception Clause where they State well
for those who have a sincere observance
or a sincere obligation of the Sabbath
from Friday Sundown to Saturday Sundown
the obligation would transfer to that
period instead so we'll give you an
exception if you're a Jew um but that's
as far as they take it can you guys
think of any other religions that might
uh maybe hold to a day other than
Saturday I think the Muslims right they
worship on Friday to at the mosque yeah
although I think in the writings of the
Quran they recognize the Sabbath but
they don't want to be associated with
the Jews and so they pick a different
day for
prayers what's fascinating about this is
if you read this document and I've read
through this section because it it
mentions the Sabbath nine times wow in
the document and 900 pages and it's all
within like a couple of paragraphs
within a page of each other they realize
that they can't make this change very
easily so they resort to forcing the
businesses and hitting them in their
pocketbook like okay so if you're going
to make people work on the Sabbath
because you're all greedy consumerist
capitalist then we're going to make you
pay the workers more wow right and is in
my mind the way that works out is
obviously you have the exception clause
and so they can kind of shift the
workforce around a little bit at least
in the beginning right like okay well
those people that don't want to you know
that can't work on the Sabbath we'll
shift them to Sunday so we can keep open
on those days you know the people that
are working on Sunday we'll shift them
to a another day or whatever but then
I also think over time this is going to
get tighter yeah right they're going to
squeeze and pretty soon it will be
basically like no weekend work right
well you know the big thing that I could
see with that too is um this looks
friendly in having an exception Clause
here it does but um I could easily see
maybe a smaller business who doesn't
have the resources to pay the extra
money or I could even see somebody from
another religion uh coming and bringing
a law suit and stating this exception
right here violates the equal protection
Clause of the 14th Amendment right so
what you're doing is you're privileging
those who maybe want to you know don't
go by the default of Sunday and go with
Saturday you're privileging them and
you're giving them an exemption and
that's that's denying the rights of
everybody else to equal protection under
the law yeah yeah so then I think
what'll happen is once once it squeezes
I think to compensate businesses will
shift their hours because they're still
interested in making money so you shift
your Workforce and you start opening a
little later and you close a little
later and you have an overlap in the
middle so like take some place like
Sam's Club right they they're not open
24/7 maybe they open at 8: so they'll
start opening at 600 or 7 and if they
close at 8 they'll be open till like 9
or something right and just make those
expansive hours because those people
aren't going to be able to go at their
normal times and if they're at work they
can't go while they're at work right so
they're going to have to have extended
hours to go either before or
after wow what happened with with
Chick-fil-A again there was like an
issue with them being closed on Sunday
and there was some politician that
attacked them for it really yeah that
was um U I think one of the one of the
Senate uh leaders who uh went after them
for that and you know there's this idea
that um they're being denied religious
liberty as far as that goes there um and
so he's promised to come back and fight
for them and so there's this idea that
you know maybe we need to come and
protect businesses like Chick-fil-A with
a law like this H that's really
interesting so like I I wonder I'm just
curious if this was an issue of well
they just don't want to be open on
Saturday or Sabbath well then would they
have been left alone you know as in as
in like nobody would fight for them but
when when it comes to Sunday you see the
opposite happening like they the
politicians want to stand up for them
because they're keeping Sunday well they
have the same values yeah so you know
that's actually been an issue that's
been brought up before the United States
Supreme Court recently as well postal
worker yeah postal worker gra versus to
Joy and of course you know there was a
Walgreens pharmacist a few years back
who brought a similar case for Saturday
but was denied hearing before The
Supreme Court but it was a Sunday keeper
who got heard and ultimately protected
that's so interesting do you know why
his case got to the Supreme Court you
know what his issue was the postal
worker yeah M he was having to work on
Sunday and he indicated that the reason
he was having to work on Sunday the
reason the post office was requiring him
to work on Sunday is because Amazon was
shipping out so many packages it was
hard for the postal service to keep up
with normal business hours of operation
so they extended that into the weekend
so people could get their
packages so here's where you see that
consumerism commercialism and all that
and like iy can't even get a break can't
be off cuz people are too
greedy you know uh this idea is getting
so more uh much more prevalent today uh
this was Donald Trump's appointee to the
administrative uh State and uh you can
see here the administrative conference
of the United States Adrien vermule he's
a Harvard law professor one of the
things that he's been tweeting here
recently is what exactly do post-
liberals want to do and the answer here
is to ban porn ban positivism Sabbath
laws economic solidary and corporatism
and stewardship of nature uh you can
think of that in maybe the encyclical
laato C for example um in addition
sari uh writing for Deseret News is
actually he was asked the question would
you support restored Sabbath laws and
more broadly public activism towards
policies of this nature he says that's
my jam man definitely he used to be the
editor for the New York Post a co-op Ed
and so we're seeing this idea of Sabbath
law is becoming much more prevalent
today but what is a a post liberal to me
a liberal is somebody that wants to I
don't know they seem more liberal that's
in the title but what is a post- liberal
well I I think of a post- liberal as you
know basically their illusion towards
the culture in United States is getting
burnt out on the extremism that we've
seen uh so this somebody who's
experienced where Liber liberalism leads
yeah and so there needs it's like the
pend swing and right now there's a lot
of liberalism out there and we're seeing
the world in chaos I mean there's you
know they're trying
to call pedophilia sexual orientation
and things like that so we're getting to
the point where we're like okay
something needs to
change um so why would this guy be in
favor of Sabbath laws and what what
exactly is a Sabbath law well uh perhaps
we can hear it from himself I've got a
little clip here to play this is from
Jonathan Barry uh who was the editor for
chapter 16 of project 2025 which talked
about the Sabbath but there there are
implications for social conservative
values across many issues uh one of the
interesting proposals um that that
you've laid out in in Project 2025
handbook from Heritage is uh stuff
around the Sabbath what what are some of
the ideas that you have there yes um so
uh this is it sounds it sounds
controversial um uh in many respects it
is a it is a return to something that
basically always everyone ever had um uh
and it it's specifically the idea of um
encouraging Sabbath rest um through
discouraging Commerce um on on the
Sabbath um the the the proposal that's
in our book is amending the the basic
Federal overtime law federal labor
standards act to require that overtime
be paid uh for all work uh done on the
Sabbath um oh interesting yes um so I
don't think um uh I I don't think I
don't think Congress has um the
authority to mandate like a national
closing on on the Sabbath this was that
was always a a state decision um to do
that but let me add it was always a
state decision to do that they did and
and yeah I'm not you know I'm not saying
this practice was uniform homogeneous
whatever but um very very widely spread
and only only recently in the last um
few decades um have uh have Most states
moved moved away from this um so this is
um I think this is about as far as the
federal government could could properly
go in this space um but it would be an
encouragement an inducement um uh to um
to to rest really to kind of coordinate
commercial activity for the other six
days of of the week which is as for as
as long as we've had saboten uh
civilization you know beginning like
beginning in Israel and continuing into
Christendom um this is something that's
been increasingly a part of the rhythm
of Civic life uh most ly for people to
have space to worship and honor God um
and and secondly to have times of
communal rest uh with their families and
with their communities yeah he you know
he he states that it's never been
Federal but uh there have definitely
been
pushes yeah I was I was hoping you'd
bring that up and the thing is you
listen to him and it's like it sounds so
good right but then it's always framed
for the majority like what about the
minority person that does go along with
that like they're always going to suffer
right we've seen we've
seen and and I think you'll talk about
this we've seen Sabbath sorry Sunday
laws put into place many times this is
not new you know where it's mandated
well you need to rest on Sunday you and
you know spend time with your family and
hopefully that makes you go to church
and and by the way you should probably
work on Saturday or Sabbath you know
like and to me it's like why like if
you're so so all about religion and
Christianity then why do you have to
enforce people to worship right that's
really what it is it's forcing people to
worship on the day that you think you're
they're supposed to worship instead of H
allowing people to have their own
relationship with God their own
conscience their
own conversion experience and say you
know what I've studied the Bible and
this is what I believe is true true and
I want to follow the scriptures these
guys aren't alone I've got a few more
Clips here I was going to show you this
is Dr Chad pecknold from the Catholic
University of America and he says it a
little bit more explicitly so here I
want to
propose as a bull work as a makee as a
condition for addressing material
questions in a non-materialist way a
public orientation to God then reflected
where reflected in concrete ways in
national holidays in Civic liturgies in
laws indeed Sabbath laws Sunday laws
that would require a cessation of
what Commerce now if you guys go to
National conservatism uh which they're
you know big liberal think tank as well
one of the books that they're promoting
recently is the case for Christian
nationalism by a PhD author Steven wolf
um he's been interviewed here recently
I'm sure you guys you guys might have
seen some of his Clips here but I've got
a couple of them here that highlight the
direction that he's willing to go with
kind of crazy right let's take a look so
how do you order people how do you order
Christians uh to eternal life well you
in in an outward way you uh you do what
you can so that they can worship God and
worship God uh and uh the church can
administer word and Sacrament uh how in
particular how would you do that you'd
have Sabbath laws and Sabbath laws are
not to Simply to punish violations of
fourth Commandment but they provide the
but to provide the conditions in which
people can worship god without
distraction that's the purpose that make
it sound so good mhm yeah but he takes
it a little bit farther the the best
critique uh is is basically that what
you're doing is your it's a de facto
privileging of Christianity because
which religion has the Sabbath on Sunday
well it's it's Christianity and so
you're not doing on Saturday you're not
doing so you're you're you're uh you're
explicitly saying this is a Christian
land and we're going to all force you to
obey some sort of Christian um and so
that's the best critique and I would
just say uh yeah well that it is that's
exactly what it does I would just like
you know one of those things I'm not
going to reject their objection I'm just
going to affirm it yes wow we're forcing
you to become Christian mhm this sounds
like uh like the Dark Ages I know like
this has happened before where it's like
you become a Christian where your head
gets chopped off I mean it happened in
the Roman times when Constantine became
emperor of Rome and he said you know
what I think that the best religion is
actually Christianity so everybody
become Christian and if and and
Christianity became the most popular
religion and it was what got you to the
top uh in politics or whatever you did
therefore you became a Christian by name
right but there the Christians were
again people were forced to adopt
Christianity and you could see how fake
people's religion was it's not wasn't
genuine yeah nothing forced is real or
Genuine yeah and it it's never been good
it's God's laws are for us to keep out
of love out of free will not by death
decree by some King like Nebuchadnezzar
right was it Nebuchadnezzar or his son
that when he
who was it Nebuchadnezzar did it yeah I
of he threw the Daniel and the or he
threw shadra mesach and abedo in the
fire and saw that their God was real he
said okay nobody bows to my image
everybody bows to God or you get Cut in
pieces it's never good you don't force
people to worship god with the
punishment of death if you don't and I I
think that's the question of where is
this going like you were saying Keith
like will it just turn into a big
Snowball Effect where eventually it's
like well
if you don't want to worship on Sunday
then you know I'm just saying it's not
going to stop there um history already
tells us that we've gone down this road
and it's very interesting couple Clips
back the guy is like well this has never
happened you know Congress has never had
the authority to do this on a national
level but then in 1888 with the Blair
bill you had exactly that and it was
this close to passing essentially it
came down to the testimony or rebuttal
of one guy against Senator Blair his
name was at Jones and his
arguments um I think he was a history
Professor were good enough to keep that
at Bay but essentially everything's
already like on the books been there
done that we got blue laws all over this
country even though they're not
enforced and so we're just like a hair's
bread away from this all over again
first time i' ever heard of a blue law
for anybody that doesn't know I lived in
Georgia for a while and and I used to
drink alcohol and you could not buy
alcohol on Sunday and I was like always
so mad I was like what is this like I
can't buy alcohol on Sunday but that was
part of it they've gotten rid of it
since then but yeah I'm from the
Netherlands and um I know I remember
growing up there are no no shops open on
Sunday and eventually start opening up
but then um I'm assuming up until this
day at least when I was younger my early
20s I was this is what H was happening
is that if you worked on Sunday you got
to pay so I mean it's it's it's it's
everywhere you know one of the things
that they tried to do to get this bill
passed back in 1888 was there was a uh
reformer in the Women's National
Temperance uh Union and she wrote a
letter to 7th Day Believers proposing in
substance that if they would help them
to secure a Sunday law uh she would or
they would exempt them from its
penalties so that exemption Clause that
if you uh have a sincere day that's
different from Sunday will on Saturday
we'll give you an exemption in Project
2025 that's been tried before they've
tried to do this but the big concern
that I have as we go to the United
States Constitution Saturday is not
mentioned but if you go to Article 1
Section 7 Clause 2 there is a discussion
about bills that are returned to the
president within 10 days Sundays
accepted it shall have been presented to
him the same shall be a law in like
manner as he had signed it so there's
this idea with in the United States
Constitution that Sunday is protected
and this has already been tested in
Maryland versus Macwan the idea of
whether or not a Sunday law can stand up
to the United States Constitution and
when they argue it for secular purposes
like whether it's the welfare of
citizens or the welfare of the
environment um those kinds of things
allow them to escape the idea that this
is a religious law and so it becomes a
trojan horse that sneaks in when really
all it is is it's a religious law and
it's always been that way clip from the
last guy you shown what was his name
again
um uh Steven wolf yeah he's one that I
watched an interview with that he was
saying exactly that it's like it wasn't
the whole argument is not framed in a
religious liberty context it's framed in
a
social
um social what's the word I'm looking
for um economic
it wasn't it wasn't economic civil like
a social civil argument completely it's
like they're like saying like no no no
we just need to re leave religion aside
here we're not talking about religious
things we're we're coming at this from a
totally different angle and for
different reasons and that's why it
gains traction you know I was thinking
that example that you mentioned of
Nebuchadnezzar that's so true in that um
the I I believe true religion is
something that has to come from the
heart yeah and the government can never
coers that you can never change
somebody's heart through outward
external force it has to be the spirit
of God moving within you right yep and
there's other countries too where it's
like you if you visit North Korea or
something you have to bow to this image
and put a rose on the Statue you think
people are really loving this person
that they're having they're being forced
to bow to you really get a resentment
for that person one of the big arguments
they had to back in the day is to you
know did allowing extra time off
actually promote morality and one of the
things that they found is yeah you would
get Society to have a day off but that
didn't necessarily mean that they would
use it for the right purposes people
would go out and get drunk go Riot go do
all kinds of things because they had
free time on their hands and were uh
using that time in a way that they
shouldn't yeah so it doesn't it doesn't
promote the morality of society at all
it it also doesn't I mean I see the
argument about Commerce and stuff but it
doesn't shop it doesn't stop people from
shopping online they can go and then
spend the whole day on Amazon or they
can be like oh I got all this free time
I can go out and watch porn or whatever
you know it doesn't solve any of that
like you said people can still go out
and drink of course if the blue laws are
active that probably wouldn't be
happening so much a lot of states is
like you can't buy it until noon or
something like that unless the
government cracks down real bad and it's
like there's no internet on Sunday just
in China I didn't think you could really
control the internet but you can in
China they Bann like you couldn't search
tankman I don't know if you've seen the
famous picture of a a man standing in
front of a line of tanks and he was you
know he was taking a stand but you can't
search that in China it's banned um so
there's ways to like for the government
to control what you look at I don't
think the
US stand for that like the people if you
just like shut off the internet that
would create some some big waves real
fast I did um I have seen the blue laws
before and I looked it up before and
there there's this website a secular
website called today I found out feed
your brain anyone can look this up it
says what are blue laws and it's
interesting here it says the first blue
law although not called that at the time
was enacted in colonial Virginia in 1610
and it mandated mandated Church
attendance at both morning and afternoon
services on Sundays a a first time
offender lost his provision and
allowance for a whole week wow this is
making me think of buying and selling
you cannot buy or sell because we're
going to apparently they had a system
where there was an allowance given and
if you didn't you weren't seen at church
on Sunday morning and evening you had
your allowance cut off for a whole week
the second offense in addition to losing
his allowance would be whipped what and
a third violation was supposedly
punished by death though there's debate
over whether accounts of early blue laws
were in some cases exaggerated or not so
you think about this prophetically
you're enforcing worship like Revelation
says with the penalty of losing your
allowance or ability to buy and sell and
persecution and death exactly what
Revelation talks about dude that is
crazy and the fact that this is
happening before within the United
States that's supposed to be the land of
the free this is like literally a fre
Freedom being taken away from us this
the 1600s I'm not sure Virginia colonial
Virginia was that like the beginning of
yeah in United States history that's one
of the one of the first instances that
you have you know going back to the uh
maybe the Reformation era there were
councils that made decrees against
subgroups like the Wen Seas or others um
that for the crime of heresy and and
other similar crimes that they could not
have any Commerce or any business and
there was even some discussion about
William the Conqueror back in the day
Roger hon talks about it uh in some of
the annals of English History where
there was anybody who was found
disobedient to the apostolic sea or the
the papal hierarchy you couldn't buy or
sell wow so you know the Bible says
history repeats itself there's no new
thing under the sun you see like this is
happened Dark Ages this happened in the
within the United States and and some
people might think you guys are crazy
like what makes you think we're headed
in the same direction but this is
religious freedom being attacked and
we're not sitting here saying like oh
well you know like the Sabbath keepers
are being attacked we're saying this is
an issue because if you are a Christian
whether you worship on Sabbath or Sunday
or what other day this is your religious
freedom that's under attack yeah this
like he said this this Heritage
Foundation has been around for a while I
mean they're not they're not the New
Kids on the Block and if you look at
their website and read through their
documentation they don't care who the
conservative president is they really
don't as far as they're concerned he's
just a figure ahead and they're the ones
kind of running the show because they
have every single area of public policy
outlined and to tell Congress and the
president this is how the law should be
written well it seems like no matter red
or blue you know conservative or liberal
it's this is a good idea in their eyes
it's like the Republicans are going to
say yeah it's great we're getting the
country back to God and but the Liberals
they can say yeah it's going to save the
environment and and things like that so
it's like a win-win the way it's set up
unless you're Al I think it would be
harder to push this if you had a liberal
president and a liberal
cabinet because depends on how you sp
there's certain things in there that
yeah they would be for but by and large
I think they wouldn't be as likely and
they specifically State you know like
conservative President we need
conservative people in office so if
you're not on that train they're
probably less likely to work work with
you would be my guess unless they're
just ultimatum I think one of the
concerns that I would have about project
2025 as a whole though is how they have
framed it in terms of banning porn or or
um you know framing it in the sense that
this is for the benefit of the family is
that there's going to be a lot of people
who see the chaos of today who see the
rampant uh immorality in America and are
fed up and looking for a solution and
for them this is going to look like a
solution but they're not going to
realize the the other side to it and I
think those are the people that are not
voting you know they're kind of like
this silent silent I don't know if
they're a majority but there's like a
silent group of people if you look at
the polls like most people in
America I don't even know if it's the
majority really
vote you know maybe that's been up in
more recent terms but by and large I
don't I don't think the majority of
people get out to the polls yeah and so
that's where it really gets its power is
you know when you really get to people's
heartstrings and and and pull on these
conservative values that they're just
tired of seen in the news but never done
anything about I think that's where you
see I think people are just Los hope
losing faith in the government they're
like what's the point of voting it's
like choose the best evil you know the
greater of the two I remember reading in
the annals of uh or some historical
records about ancient Babylon that when
Nebuchadnezzar set up the image as a
religious test that there was a lot of
chaos going on in his kingdom at that
time that there had even been hand toand
fighting within the palace and so there
was this idea that to bring peace to a
fractured Empire there needs to be this
religious test that brings everybody
together
and it presents a question of whose side
are you
onh we're facing that in a nation today
where there's a massive divide and I
think people are looking for how do we
find a way forward so that we don't
completely crumble as a nation yeah did
you see there is an alternative view in
this document as well not that it
necessarily represents the view they
want to push but they basically contrast
and say you know according to there's
the one point of view is flsa you know
Fair labor standards act that we should
encourage you know making it more
expensive for
employers um other conservatives they
say believe that the government's role
is to protect the free exercise of
religion by eliminating barriers as
opposed to erecting
them and
so the you know there is they do
recognize that that not everybody thinks
that
way um but they're also not as apt to
promote that Viewpoint as well that's
not what they're going for I think the
concern too is that this is framed as
just the first opening shot if you will
so what we're seeing here could easily
change over time and could easily get
much more uh serious in terms of what
the demand is so he talked about well I
don't know that we can necessarily
demand ferally that every business be
shut down but that could change over
time and I think that this demonstrates
the flexibility of and the fluid
fluidity of the push currently but
during Co there were only certain types
of businesses that were allowed to be
open mhm you know so you see that same
track with the ability to be set up it's
like okay well all the healthcare has to
be open all the Emergency Services have
to be open utilities have to be open
that kind of thing it's like boil it
down to like what's necessary for
infrastructure of society everything
else close it down and we've seen this
in Europe actually for years I was in
Romania at the be at the end of 2023 and
the beginning of
2024 and I was talking about this
project 2025 with some of them because
they have their eyes on American
politics they want to see what's going
on and and stuff and they said actually
like this kind of stuff has been
happening in Europe for mhm 20 years
yeah you know there there's like all
kinds of places you will not find shops
open to shop at what is their reasoning
is it a Christian thing too yeah I mean
same kind of thing I mean it's the same
kind of influence the same kind of
political leanings it's about the
protection of society and the family and
all of that and and of course Europe is
more probably heavily Catholic you know
at least in its Deep Roots cuz you have
several countries that that you know go
back and identify with Catholicism for
thousands of years so or at least you
know 1500 1600 years so they're
um they're more likely to latch on to
that and and you even see it in certain
cultures so for
example um and and I confirm this with
Alex when he was working here if I go
and speak somewhere and it's largely a
Hispanic group
okay I'm pastor and it doesn't matter
what my credentials are like pastor
pastor pastor pastor pastor and you
watch and all those people they look up
to the pastor right the pastor is the
man guy can hardly do no wrong like it's
pastor this pastor that right not saying
the pastor doesn't have his place but
it's way more emphasized in their
culture why is that well they have
Catholic roots and those roots were
always like the priest like it was
almost like Society revolved around the
priest like you go to the priest for
this you go to the priest for that and
whatever the priest says this is this is
the thing and that's trans you know it's
translated down even when they become
Protestant and so you still have some of
that in these other countries wow so one
of the things that I I think uh you know
you've got a point there that I'm seeing
in a lot of their literature is this
idea of synchronized rest the idea that
we all need to be unified and on the
same page you don't have that if you got
half the country or maybe a small
minority who says no no no we're going
to keep it you know on Saturday instead
of Sunday and what about those those
Muslims well you know one of the things
that the New York Times had this last
year was Dubai had started shifting to
where they were going to start closing
on Sundays and start realigning
themselves or or aligning more with the
west and so there's a change there's
even some Turkish shop uh mall owners
who are starting to
request specifically Sunday to be
protected by law you also see this in
Malaysia as well which you would think
of is you know how is that a Christian
Nation but yet some of their political
leaders are starting to demand Sunday be
protected as well same with Israel
they're starting to Cave too yeah
Jerusalem times has been talking about
that yeah wow yeah they're starting to
be like well you know I mean and and
where it all hits is economy it's like
if you're if you're missing out on that
you know that day it it really really
hits people so even even some of the
Jews are starting to you know compromise
at least at least intellectually
entertain some of those ideas so and
that's that's what I think if it's like
Seventh Day Adventist aren't the only
ones that are like this you have 7th Day
Baptists you have Jews you have Muslims
you have sth day Church of God you have
all kinds of denominations or groups
that have a different Sabbath if you
will than Sunday mhm what about them you
know but going they're the minority I I
think that anybody watching this has
to see that this is not a small issue
right this is happening across the world
and even in Arabic and Jewish Nations um
I mean there's something up with this
you know guys one of the things that
I've been noticing is this seems to be
an increasingly popular discussion and
talking point here one of the
individuals referenced here was actually
soab Omari he's the editor of the New
York Post and he Wall Street Journal yes
Wall Street Journal what we've lost in
rejecting the Sabbath and they talked
here about how we need to kind of return
to this idea of Sunday being protected
by rest but you know even businesses of
today like Bed Bath and Beyond are
referencing the idea of Sunday
relaxation in some of their ads you have
this being a talking point not only for
the Wall Street Journal but for Deseret
News it's interesting that during covid
this was a talking point that I saw uh
to the tune of probably 500 plus
articles that I was seeing in various
languages around the world where you're
seeing in many countries you see a push
this direction we can see this in part
of Rico we can see this in the United
States even some Baptist speakers are
pushing for Sunday as a day of rest the
idea of Piggly Wiggly perhaps following
the Chick-fil-A standard wow um and you
know it comes from uh countries that you
wouldn't necessarily expect for example
Malaysia in Malaysian news Hano who's
one of the uh Malaysian politicians was
stating that Sunday should be made a day
of rest and family day so they just kind
of promoted as family day you know not a
worship day yeah you see it in Taiwan as
well there's petitions being put out
there that there's a right or rest day
or day off once a week Samoa you see a
push for that as well that they want to
ban Sunday trading and some you know
here in the United States we see how
individuals like Adrien vermule who
again he's Donald Trump's appointee to
the administrative conference we can see
him retweeting ideas from saramari and
others that BW laws are very pro-worker
and Pro-Am so unions specifically are
some of the main driving Power Players
to get these enacted and of course this
has been very popular in Germany where
Sundays on the construction site there
were some individuals that broke the
basic law article 139 of the bundas
Republic Deutschland and they were fined
€1,200 wait they were fined for what if
they worked on Sunday yeah yeah exactly
and you know in in Germany of course the
unions right there have been really big
in getting these enacted you got the ver
Union you've got uh uni Europa you've
got uh cesi several different trade
unions that are that are headed this
direction and advocating before the
members of European Parliament of course
during covid we saw people being booked
in uh certain regions of India for
violating Sunday lockdowns the
Mississippi Governor declared Sunday a
Statewide day of fasting and prayer wow
you know in uh of course Matthew mccon
it's getting very popular in Hollywood
as well in certain sectors and in France
the idea of a Lords day act that was
previously nullified by the Supreme
Court there was a petition that was
delivered to the French National
Assembly to get that Federal Lords day
act reenacted in Quebec so it it's it's
getting super popular yeah this is
worldwide there's uh there's more on the
Puerto Rico uh Sunday closures as well
uh we have closures being pushed in
Italy we see uh of course in ch a hefty
fine this was actually over in Greece
there was a butcher who opened his shop
on Sunday and he was he had to pay 3,000
that is
crazy yeah so um one of the things that
I found interesting here though is in
the United States there was a newspaper
called the Union Springs Harald and this
particular section right here I found
interesting they stated that you know
the Sunday blue laws are not
unconstitutional or discriminatory and
this opens a way for the present
confused contradictory local and state
laws to be replaced by a national law
that will standardize the enforcement of
Sunday blue laws All Over America W so
they want something Federal here closing
all across Europe and you can see over
in some of the the movements that are
gathering to enact Sunday laws that it's
coming together of you know federations
of trade unions churches Bankers so
Financial structure here getting on
board and you can see how you know the
environmentalists like green party
Switzerland and a lot of unions the
Methodist Church everybody is coming
together and trying to head this
direction you have them pushing for
initiatives like zero carbon
Sunday restoring a universal weekly rest
day for the human Fraternity in the
planet I find this so interesting I
remember it was probably still during
covid or a little bit after I watched
the nature documentary and it was
specifically about what happened in
nature during Co when everything was
shut down and I remember they said in
that
documentary that oh it would be good for
nature and for the environment to have
one day of rest a week yeah they didn't
say Sunday but one day of rest a week
and here there's talking specifically
about Sunday why not any other day of
the week why Sunday for the sake of the
environment yeah so even here in the
United States Fox News um asked a
question here about a year ago look at
the number of like likes and reactions
24 almost 25,000 you know 7,000 shares
this was Fox New York should all stores
close on Sunday to allow staff a day off
to recuperate wow and they're not even
um spinning this for Co it's just in
general so this was um this was Peru
right here that was announcing in the
middle of covid on Sunday no one is
allowed to leave home what what is it
about Sunday I mean I I get it co they
were trying to shut people like stay in
your homes and all that kind of thing
but now these articles it's like just on
Sunday that's when CO's out there don't
spread it on Sunday right yeah like like
Co is no respector of
persons so like why Sunday like you said
and like why did we see this over and
over and over and over again like
they're not it's not like ah Sunday and
then oh Thursday and Wednesday like no
it's just Sunday that's
crazy yeah you know this has been going
on there there's a push now with crisis
magazine to bring back the blue laws in
Geneva there's referendums against the
Sun opening we see even uh in other
nations as well like the Inuits um where
there was a reference to naming Sunday
as a day of rest and we can see like at
at one point you know if I go to Google
news and like Google this during the
height of covid as just article after
article after article the EU Bishops
with Kacy we can see that they were
pushing it as well and of course Verity
which is that German Union uh has been
quite active in demanding that as well I
just think it's interesting that they
keep talking about Sunday rest and they
they do throw the Bible out there so
when did this become a day of rest
according to the Bible I mean why is it
Sunday I mean we know that Sabbath means
seven it means rest but we keep seeing
the Sunday thing well you know it's
interesting if you go back to the early
Church in the time of St Jerome and Lady
Paula um one of the things that there
was a bishop in the 17th century uh
Bishop white who actually noted that um
in the early church with Lady Paula he
said the most devout Christians uh did
ordinary work on Sundays so lady Paula
was out there you know after after they
had a Sunday meeting they'd go out there
and work they didn't rest on Sunday yeah
there's no there is no
biblical like evidence or mandate or
anything for the worship of Sunday in
fact when you look at it just kind of a
even from a textual statistical
standpoint you have eight references at
most to Sunday in the New Testament the
whole of the New Testament eight wow
there's nine references to the Sabbath
just in the book of Acts alone wow
so of those eight five of them are the
same event they're basically just saying
people went to the tomb on Sunday when
Jesus rose from the grave so that's in
all the gospels right and so you're
basically five of them are the same
event you have eight total you're
talking about four different things
total right so in history though
when when you had um the first century
Church um this is the the apostolic
church right and and after that within
like the first hundred years that the
church
existed they were
different and the Romans actually were
very religiously
tolerant um but the Romans had big
problems with the Jews right because the
Jews were always stirring up things
hated the Romans always pushing back
right so even though the Romans were
religiously tolerant they didn't like
the Jews okay so if you're a Christian
and you're worshiping on the Sabbath and
you don't eat this and you eat the same
kind of food as the Jews Like no pork
and no alcohol so if you're following
many of the same ideals you're easily
confused with the Jews who the Romans
hate so what happens well over time they
start to distance themselves from the
Jews by making compromises in their
beliefs yeah one of those beliefs was
the day that they worshiped on yeah and
there there were different schools of
thought depending on where you were at
in in
um in
um the area around Israel in in
Palestine so you have the alexandrian
school of thought you have the Antioch
school of thought you know and it's like
different ones uh went down at different
times and different different different
areas rose up as you know I guess places
of influence and power it's like why you
have later on you have the bishop of
Rome being a prominent figure because
Rome became a center of influence and
power wow so along with that wasn't just
the day of worship it was also dietary
things Christians started eating
differently than their Jewish uh
brothers and sisters because they didn't
want to be
confused and and Reed that persecution
and hatred that the Romans bestowed upon
the Jewish people yeah I mean we see
where the Constantine came in right
emperor Constantine uh in Rome and he
was a pagan he was a pagan he became a
Christian due to some Vision or dream uh
of I think it was like a cross or before
that he was persecuting Christians right
yes he was persecuting Christians before
so he had this dream of this cross and
this is all historical uh knowledge but
um he therefore is like well I guess I
got to be a Christian now because the
Christian God gave me the victory over
this battle that I'm about to fight or
was about to fight and so he says well
the whole nation needs to be Christian
and you know obviously there were people
who were keeping the Sabbath and there
were the pagans who were keeping Sunday
in under of the sun god which was the
first day of the week because up until
that point Christians were still keeping
the biblical Sabbath which was Friday
evening Sunset till Saturday evening
Sunset the fourth Commandment the fourth
Commandment
yes um and so for him to make it easier
to draw the pagans in he said well um
you you know let's just allow it you you
you worship God on Sunday and first it
was Sabbath and Saturday and Sunday and
like Keith would explaining due to the
anti-Semitism eventually Sunday became
more popular and over the course of
centuries we've forgotten all about it
but it's the only commandment in the
first in the Ten Commandments that says
remember right so like God knew we were
going to forget so that's why this is
something that's important for us to
discuss and why we have James here
because um you know we have this issue
of this push
to um worship only on Sunday and to do
away with Sabbath keeping well what I
think is interesting about Constantine I
remember reading where he said judaizers
would be persecuted so like Keith was
saying you separate yourself from the
Jews so the Christians were like okay
yeah we're going to keep Sunday and he
said that all shops must be closed you
have to honor the venerable day of the
sun mhm so if there was has some
Antichrist agenda to um you know to
enforce worship on a worldwide scale and
to you know deceive the world into
worshiping a different day and to break
God's Commandments yeah so what do you
think this what do you think this is
headed prophetically or what's the
danger I mean what what are you
predicting if this were to happen
tomorrow what would our close future
look like we're not even talking about
tomorrow what we're talking about is
starting January 1 or whenever the
president takes office which is you know
around I think January 19 or 2021
something like that
2025 that's that's essentially when the
clock starts ticking and again I
personally I think it depends on who
winds up in the Oval Office if it's a
republican I think this thing is a slam
dunk I think one of the things that's
going to drive us this direction too is
you look at the narrative in popular
culture and media today I don't know if
you guys saw the trailer for that new
movie Civil War buten seen it there's a
discussion now increasingly in the
United States about this idea that we
might be headed towards a second Civil
War just how divided our nation is and
there's also a lot of discussion about
famine as far as that goes now if you
combine Civil War and famine if you go
back to the fish markets and the French
Revolution and some of the driving
factors of what push people to violence
and a coercive
State you take away somebody's food
that's going to push him to extremes
yeah um there's a lot of factors that
could drive this and make it really
happen really quickly well on that note
um we are wrapping up today's show you
know this is again not a discussion of
politics saying this party is something
you should vote for for this
party but we are seeing prophecy being
fulfilled in Project 2025 and like we've
discussed this is an issue of religious
freedom whether you are a Sabbath
keeping Christian of various
denominations that keep the Sabbath
whether you are a Muslim whether you are
a Jew whether you're of any other
religion or whether you are a Sunday
keeping Christian this is attacking your
religious freedom and so we encourage
you go to your Bible look it up
understand the prophecies dig dig
deep and understand where this is headed
right and also speak up and take it into
prayer when you go and vote for a new
president ask the lord lord whom should
I vote for or should I perhaps withhold
from voting and I believe that God will
lead you in that and besides that stay
close to Jesus stay in prayer stay in
the word so that no matter what happens
and may fall upon us um Jesus says that
he will never leave us nor forsake us
because we want to be true to God's word
um as the reformer said in the Dark Ages
Sola scriptura by the scriptures and the
scriptures alone and that is our stance
we want to stand by the scriptures and
the scriptures alone and we all here
want to worship God as we believe the
scriptures have told us though the
heavens may fall and we hope that that
is your decision as well if you like
this video make make sure you give us a
thumbs up make sure you hit the
Subscribe button we're here every single
Friday at 12:00 p.m. ET with a new show
we also got videos coming out during the
week we also got a podcast if you want
to dive deep into anything from the
Bible or prophecy look up the little
light Studios podcast Mikey also has a
new YouTube channel well little light
has a new YouTube channel and Mikey is
managing it what is it Mikey we have
little light kids if you got little ones
and you don't want them exposed to the
things that of the world is just
throwing at them we're putting out
content as much as we can we want to put
out biblical safe content for your
little ones so check that out a little
like kids also if you want to share your
faith and support our ministry you can
do so by getting a t-shirt or in this
case Keith is wearing a hoodie quite
ironically about the creation and the
seventh day right so you can get that on
lightwear do shop if you want to support
our ministry financially we really
really appreciate that we are so
appreciative of all of our donors you
can go to
[Music]
if you're looking for good wholesome
educational content for your children
subscribe to our new channel little
light
[Music]
kids
yeah